well brian the white house expected to
announce this week that anyone who got
the two dose either the pfizer or the
modern vaccine should get a booster shot
now this comes amid a surge in cobit
cases and also a struggle to convince
the millions who are still unvaccinated
to get a first shot
americans who received the pfizer or
moderna vaccine could start getting a
booster shot as early as mid-september
if the fda approves it
boosters would likely be the same brand
as the first two and would come eight
months after the second dose part of our
operational focus was ensuring we had
enough supply to provide booster shot
pfizer said a small study showed people
with a third dose had higher levels of
antibodies including against the delta
variant dr william shaffner is an
infectious disease expert at vanderbilt
as with most vaccines
after a time
protection wanes and so we have to give
our immune system a reminder and that's
what a booster would do
u.s officials are also reviewing vaccine
data out of israel where residents over
50 are being offered a booster i'm very
grateful that i can
take the third shot people with
compromised immune systems are already
allowed to get a booster shot if there's
future boosters and they tell me to go
get them i'm going to go get them the
delta variant continues to overwhelm
hospitals across the country and it's a
struggle to convince the unvaccinated to
roll up their sleeves there's a large
group of people out there still
unvaccinated i wish they would all get
vaccinated this afternoon
now officials are still waiting for more
data before giving advice on that one
shot the johnson and johnson vaccine but
starting today in new york city people
who want to visit an indoor gym
restaurant or museum will have to show
proof of vaccination